- I come to Clay County.
Here where I'm at now,
Manchester, Kentucky.
Ain't no jobs, nothing.
And I told the judge
that I said, your honor,
I said, I wouldn't be this way,
if you-ins had something for me to do.
And you know that's true.
That's what's wrong with these kids
today here at Clay County,
there's nothing for 'em to do.
There's no kind of a recreation.
There's no swimming pool.
There's no pool room.
Well, there's gambling,
but there's nothing.
There's no kind of no movies.
Just a little dead town.
- [Mark] All right Jerry Lee.
Jerry Lee, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jerry] I'm from Manchester, Kentucky.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents growing up?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How's your childhood?
- Pretty rough.
Really, really rough.
There was a lot of verbal abuse.
And I guess abuse that where you,
see your parents hitting one
another, knife stabbings.
- [Mark] How bad did the violence get?
- It got really bad.
And I guess it got so
bad, my mom got sick.
I think that's the reason he took her,
at that age, because my
dad would throw knives
that would stick to the back of her head,
while she was trying
to take up her us kids.
- [Mark] So your dad?
- He was really bad jealous.
- [Mark] So your dad killed your?
- No, my real mom died of natural causes.
- [Mark] But your dad
killed your step mom?
- Yes.
After my real mom died, he
got remarried to a woman that
he went to school with.
And then 11 years,
'til January the 5th, 2005.
January the 1st, 2005, when it happened,
at six o'clock in the morning.
I was going to work.
I lived in another county.
I was taking my wife to work,
and she ran out the door
saying they thought it was me,
when it was my dad who murdered.
He was held up in their house.
I thought he'd killed hisself,
but he was in there with my mom.
He kept her in there for two
days before he passed out.
I don't see how he coulda done that.
But I think what he did, he
just had so much in his mind,
where he didn't get help.
Like, I want help 'cause I
could turn out really bad,
and I don't wanna go that way.
I'm gonna choose the good path if I can.
But daddy, I think he's what changed me,
made me who I am today,
because there are people done things,
I only did was to do good in life,
'cause it gets harder and it does.
It's true.
It gets harder.
- [Mark] So how far did you go in school?
- 'Til the eighth.
- [Mark] Eighth grade?
- I went into high school,
but they told me where that you graduated.
And I said, I graduated
without signing a diploma?
That was, matter of fact,
just right over there.
You see the school, Horse Creek.
- [Mark] And so drugs are very prevalent.
- Yes, yes they were.
- [Mark] Like here in
Clay County, Kentucky.
What age did you get started with that?
- I got started on drugs at probably,
I'm gonna say seven
years old with marijuana.
And actually this boy's daddy out here,
and my uncle Pete, the one-armed guy,
started marijuana when I was young.
- [Mark] And then you got
into harder drugs at what age?
- Yes,
at 15, I think.
No, 17.
Pain pills.
- [Mark] And pain pills
are a big thing out here?
- Yes.
Well, I'm gonna take that back.
I was getting a bottle of
Xanax since me 14 years old.
Went to a doctor and told
him that I needed something,
like the baby made me nervous.
I was down on 'em.
- [Mark] So you had a child at what age?
- 15.
- [Mark] 15?
- He's the same age as Jack Charles,
that guy in that truck out there.
There's a small difference in them.
- [Mark] And how old was it your wife,
or the mother of the child?
- The what now?
- [Mark] The mother of
your child was how old?
- She was, say, 16 and I was 15.
- [Mark] Okay, and you guys got married?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how many
children do you have?
- I got four.
- [Mark] Four, and you
were around to raise them?
- Did what?
- [Mark] Did you raise your kids?
- No, I did two where I couldn't.
I tried to raise my kids.
I was expected to like a regular parent
would the rest of your life,
but I didn't get to do it all,
because my women I had
was around warrants.
I tried to raise 'em in a car.
'Cause when we split up,
I didn't have nowhere to take 'em to.
I would stay in a car for a week,
week at a time, and then I think we'd go
to a lake in Corbin and
wash off me and my son.
But he thought we's
camping, but we didn't,
he didn't know what I was doing.
He didn't know we didn't have
a home, him and a little dog.
Now he's 19 years old, he's asking me.
But my son, he knows when I'm sad.
'Cause he seen me here not too long ago,
around one o'clock at night a-crying
up there at Mike's Pit Stop,
arguing with the lady that I'm with now.
He did think I kept
things hidden from him.
Told him I was happy, but
he caught me that night.
- [Mark] You get depressed sometimes?
- Yeah, all the time now.
It hurts to think,
why did it happen?
Why did my daddy do that?
Why didn't he do things different?
And I see that there ain't
no jobs here where I'm at,
and he had to work as a night watchman.
He done it for 21 years, I think.
I just seen him when
I come in from school.
When I was getting up in the mornings,
they would get us up around 6:00, 6:30.
I wouldn't have no time
to even speak with him,
I don't even know my dad.
I left, I left home at 15 years old.
Then my mom died.
- [Mark] What drugs have you done?
- I've done, maybe everything
they have down here.
I've done, I guess it'd be
a lower-set hydrocodone.
Morphine.
My favorite drug was cocaine.
I've done everything
that you know of I guess
except beer, alcohol.
And I just started drinking it
until here on the last of 2012.
And I just got out of prison.
'Cause I knew my home wasn't the same.
I could tell.
And that's when I had a son
come see me in Louisville,
I stayed at a halfway house.
That's what helped me, that place.
It saved my life, saved me
and probably other people,
'cause I took it serious.
Because I knew if I
didn't go to this place,
or tried to get help, I'd never get it.
But the guy that run the place,
he was a colored man, his name was Joe.
To me it was more or less like a court.
But he said, Jerry you're so quiet,
I didn't even know you was here.
'Cause I went up to him on the last week
of my time there at that place,
and thanked him for the
classes and helping me realize,
but he's telling I should've spoken up.
And that same thing my
dad said, before he died.
You need to speak up son,
or people are not gonna know you here.
So now I do just like they had heard me.
I argue, I'll argue with
you, I'll fight with you.
A lot of people thinks I lie.
And then when I get mad
like that, that I did it
but I'm just trying to, I
don't have the right reason.
I guess I take it in the wrong mode
or something like a real
defensive mode like that.
I don't know if I said it
wrong to her, but I did.
It just hurt me.
- [Mark] And your prison time,
has been for what kind of stuff?
- For escapes.
To escape charges.
DUIs.
Possession.
Assault charges.
And FTAs and burglaries.
- [Mark] How far have you
traveled around the country?
Have you been anywhere?
- As far as I've been
is Jackson, Mississippi,
and Georgia,
and Cincinnati.
That's as far as I've been.
I never traveled.
That's one of my main
goals, though, travel.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 46.
- [Mark] 46.
So it's difficult for a young man
to find work here in Clay County, right?
- Yes it is.
- [Mark] You've done pretty good.
You've had some jobs.
- No, I never had a job for my life here.
I've always tried to.
- [Mark] Yeah, you've
had to travel for work,
but you made the effort to get work.
- But it was hard.
- [Interviewer] But to
stay here in Clay County,
as you've chosen to do,
makes your life very difficult, right?
- Really, really, really hard.
- [Mark] Because you're
surrounded by what?
- Drugs.
I'm surrounded by.
- [Mark] And you choose to stay here
for what reason you think?
- I will say, why I'm
choosing to stay here
is 'cause of my little brother.
So when I was telling
him out there at the end,
I said I'm leaving here if I can,
I gotta get some kind of
support to do it though.
- [Mark] And are drugs still
a problem for you today?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What are you using today?
- I use Suboxone and Neurontin,
and I use marijuana sometimes to sleep.
But the Suboxone I think,
is no different from any other drug.
It just takes the place of another drug.
But it will help you, if you use it right,
and it is prescribed.
And it took me years to get it prescribed.
I spent every dime I had
to getting that drug,
having to buy it off the street.
You know, I finally got me
a doctor now it's my chance.
If I could get me another
job, I could save my money.
I had to spend it on what
I used to call my habit every day.
I went and picked tens up.
When I moved to Clay County.
When I left Somerset, I was working,
and coming to Clay County,
here where I'm at now,
Manchester, Kentucky.
Ain't no jobs, nothing.
And I told the judge,
that, I said, your honor,
I said, I wouldn't be this way
if you-ins had something for me to do.
And you know it's true.
That's what's wrong with these kids
today here in Clay County,
there's nothing for them to do.
There's no kind of a recreation,
there's no swimming pool,
there's no pool room.
Well, there's gambling.
But there's nothing.
There's no kind of no movies.
Just a little dead town.
Used to be out here lively back then,
had a little drive-in,
now they shut it down.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends here?
- They're all dead.
I have friends I got or did have.
That's why I was gonna
tell you about me going.
If I had went with them, they chose,
I guess not working things
and that's what saved me.
I had a job.
There's a few times if I'd
went with those friends,
I wouldn't be here today, talking,
'cause the same car, the same boys
I knew went to school with these boys.
Took my best friend out and shot him
in the back, killed him.
They wanted me to go with him.
And if I'd went the next day,
I would have been killed,
they'd found me shot.
They came after me.
I think I was 17, 18 years old.
Now this boy got out here a few years.
Last year, or two year ago, I'm gonna say.
He done life since 20 years.
He's the same age I am,
and he's done 25 years.
I couldn't do that now.
Too old.
- [Mark] What are your children doing?
- What do they do?
- [Mark] What are they doing?
How old are they now?
- My oldest child, I think is 29.
And my oldest girl, is I'm gonna say 20.
My oldest boy is 19.
And my youngest girl is,
I think 11.
- [Mark] And they're still
staying here in Clay County?
- Two of them are, two are
gone in other counties.
I got a girl that lives in Corbin.
She's in a foster home.
And my boy is getting ready to be a daddy,
and I'm going to be a pawpaw.
That's one thing that's made me,
I got to get myself straightened out,
because I want to be an example.
I want to be able to tell
them, to try to guide them
in the wrong way or the right way.
You know, take that wrong path.
Don't want 'em to be nothing like I am.
- [Mark] You still talk to your kids?
- Yeah.
But that is just I think
when they want some money.
I do talk to my kids.
I tried to talk to my oldest boy,
the one that's getting
ready to be a daddy.
He said he wanted to be
a killer like his papaw.
His name is Christopher,
and it breaks my heart when he says that.
- [Mark] He says what?
- He wants to be a killer.
- [Mark] Like your dad?
- Like his papaw, yeah, my dad.
But I think they got him
some kind of help, and he's straightened.
He ain't no killer.
Hope not.
But he got him a job, when he quit school.
This happened maybe two months ago.
I ain't got no way of calling
him but I use Facebook,
and I was trying to explain to him
'cause he's going to be a dad.
Go 'em to school while
they can, or home-bound.
I just told my story.
I told him some of it,
but his girlfriend took it the wrong way.
She took it the wrong way.
I guess I said it not be to like I was.
I chose the wrong path.
I chose lower sets and stuff like that,
and she thought I was doing it now,
but I was trying to tell
my story, like I was here.
And we got into it and she blocked me.
But he told me, he said, dad
she just took it the wrong way.
Well, what I was trying to
do is to just use myself
as an example and describe how I did it,
but she thought I was talking
about the future now I guess.
But I was talking about the past.
That it destroyed my life.
That I chose the wrong road.
I chose to hung out with wrong friends,
and I had caused me to be
that way, that I am now.
- [Mark] And what's your biggest regret?
- Not finishing school.
I could have had so many good jobs,
if I would have finished school.
My education, the kind of work I do now.
I always wanted to be like an electrician
or a lineman, a good lineman,
is the best thing like coal
mining that paid top dollar,
because it was dangerous to
work for the electric company.
But you had to have a high school diploma,
and I couldn't get it.
If I had finished school,
I'd been set right now.
- [Mark] Do you regret not being
a better role model for your kids?
- Yes I do,
'cause if my dad been there for me,
and been more provided,
or a role model for me.
I didn't see my daddy.
I had nobody to be a role model.
I had to learn it all on my
own every day, every step.
It was so hard.
Every mistake I made, I paid for it.
But that next week,
when I started back in,
I wasn't gonna go back and do that again.
But I got further and further.
You're around 46 going
on almost 50 years old.
That's hard to believe.
Then all my friends didn't think that way.
They chose the wrong path.
I don't have a friend now.
Might be a few on this side.
They moved away or something,
but near Clay County ain't nobody I have.
Just wish I went farther
in school and done right.
I regret it.
- [Mark] How much do you
credit your environment
versus your family for the
path your life has taken?
Do you think it's the family
that you had around you,
the role models, or is it the fact
that you grew up in here in Clay County?
- One of my doctors told me
its the environment I'm in.
It's what they tell me that
I could take the drugs
that I take now to help me.
It's the environment,
the people I'm around.
And where I go is nothing but violence.
And where you go?
I don't have nowhere else
to run or hide no more.
So I got to take this to heart
and learn and do it fast.
Because time is going
on, you can't stop it.
Every mistake I made,
I won't do it no more.
Tired, I don't want to go jail.
I'm praying about knowing
that I feel strange,
like something's wrong,
and I'd probably be in jail next week.
Got this girl and she's
crazy as hell over me.
She never had nobody like me.
But she shouldn't be so jealous.
If you don't have trust,
you don't have nothing, man.
I'm honest to her.
I've been married three
times and I've give each one
of them women something
very special, a baby.
And they took it away from me.
They'll split us up apart from me,
from being a dad to 'em,
something that was my
lifeline to for me to do good,
because I wanted to do for
them kids that I wanted
when I was growing up.
I see these kids in school.
How did they get to
have a Mustang or that?
Or had a new home?
I wanted be able to
tell them how to do it,
and what it takes to get that goal you got
to have the will and the heart to do it.
And I had nobody to help me.
But, it's been bad.
I can go back in time.
I don't know.
I can change the subject,
and go back to what really hurt me a lot.
I would play football,
I was the best football
player here in Clay County.
I won the championship for this school.
I could get in trouble and not
even have to worry about it.
I said principal's out in life.
Then I changed school and
the bus driver took me home.
I see it's happened to a lot of kids,
I ain't ashamed to say it.
But it's hurt me.
You know, my daddy verbally hurt me bad,
and abusive I guess, with his gun belts.
But my bus driver,
and there's probably other little kids
just not spoke up and said about it.
I guess the reason my
momma and daddy let me go,
they trusted that bus driver.
But I told my mom, I didn't tell my daddy.
She knew, but she was afraid to tell him.
- [Mark] What happened
with the bus driver?
- He took me home with him.
Let me ride little horses, little ponies.
He had race horses.
Then it came eating time and laid down,
and wanted me to get into bed with him,
and he touched me and stuff.
I was 13.
And like I said, 14, 15, I was married.
And I didn't say that when I go work,
I think that people knew
I was ashamed of myself.
I could get so mad.
I've worked so hard.
I'd work harder.
He hurt me.
He broke.
I thought of it every day, every
day of my life pretty much.
But, I'm not ashamed,
I should have spoke out a long time ago.
Now just look what he's done.
Well, I didn't get to ask
for help 'til it's too late.
It's not too late.
Oh, it's not.
- [Mark] It's never too late.
- [Jerry] 'Cause there's so much
I want to say to anybody and everybody.
- [Mark] All right, Jerry.
Thank you very much.